[Musique]
vous êtes sur France 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'Afrique à la une ce soir un an après
le coup d'État les Guinéens sont
toujours dans l'attente de la liste des
membres du CNRD la composition de
l'instant sans se diriger le pays n'a
toujours pas été dévoilé malgré les
pressions de la CEDEAO et de la société
civile pour en parler nous recevrons
nous recevons ses coucouno responsable
stratégie et planification du fndc faire
de lance de l'opposition guinéenne
interdite par l'agence au pouvoir
2 millions de déplacés à l'intérieur du
pays dont 50% sont des enfants
reportages à suivre à Ouagadougou dans
un quartier qui abrite des déplacés de
Djibo déjà victime d'une attaque
meurtrière en 2019 et toujours dans
l'actualité
nous parlerons aussi des crimes commis
pendant la guerre civile au Liberia à
l'occasion de la prochaine ouverture
prochaine à Paris et c'est une première
du procès en assise de Kunti Camara un
ancien commandant rebelle soupçonné de
crime contre l'humanité
on ouvre ce journal par la Guinée cyton
nommé déjà rejeté cela n'empêche elles
ont les trois médiatrices chargées du
dialogue politique entamé ce vendredi
leur tournée auprès des partis
politiques guinéens dans ces rencontres
sans des rencontres sans le parti des
présidents
Diallo ni du fndc tous exigent la
médiation de la CEDEAO on écoute macale
Traoré porte-parole des facilitatrices
du dialogue inter-glaire
objectif de cette mission c'était
d'expliquer la méthodologie sur laquelle
nous avons travaillé pour arriver à
mettre le cadre de dialogue en place
ensuite échanger sur les modalités de la
visite du Premier ministre qui à partir
du 14 va entamer une importante tournée
auprès des entités justement pour
préparer ce cadre de dialogue qui est
très important pour nous pour mener à
bien la transition qui est en cours en
Guinée nous avons pris contact avec tout
le monde et nous allons rencontrer
toutes les entités
allez je me retourne vers c'est coucou
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
responsable stratégie et planification
du fndc le Front national pour la
défense de la Constitution monsieur
kunduno dites-nous déjà pourquoi avoir
rejeté la main tendue de ces médiatrices
et écoutez le fndc comme ses alliés je
parle des partis politiques nous n'avons
pas demandé qu'on puisse désigner des
facilitateurs ou des facilitatrices à
l'interne nous avons exigé qui est un
dialogue qui soit présidé par
l'institution sur régionale je parle de
la CEDEAO qui doit être composé du CNRD
du CNT du gouvernement des partis
politiques de l'astuce civile mais aussi
des ambassadeurs à chrétiens en Guinée
et sous la coupole du G5 comme vous le
savez nous avons une crise de confiance
entre la gente militaire et les acteurs
sociopolitiques cette crise de confiance
elle est de telle sorte que il est
impossible aujourd'hui qu'à l'interne
qu'on puisse avoir des Guinéens pour
discuter pour rapprocher les positions
nous nous avons exigé je pense bien que
la jointe doit reconstruire cette
démarche c'est une fuite en avant qui ne
va pas profiter au peuple de Guinée
c'est pourquoi le fndc n'a pas manqué
d'appeler tu t'appelais midi à des
manifestations dans le grand concret et
surtout de toi national nous parlerons
de ces manifestations mais déjà comment
est-ce que vous jugez est-ce que vous
jugez suffisante la pression qui existe
par exemple la CEDEAO sur la jante
est-ce que c'est suffisant et écoutez la
CEDEAO elle a été très docile vis-à-vis
de la jungle il y a de cela une année
elle le fait que des plaidoyer des
actions des beaux offices a fait
d'interpeller l'agenda à raison garder
ce travail a continué comme vous le
savez le sommet du 24 septembre dernier
à New York et ce semestre extraordinaire
la CEDEAO a engagé des séries de
sanctions contre les membres du Seigneur
des mais aussi les membres du
gouvernement et le bureau de CMT
d'autres sanctions vont rentrer en
vigueur si aucune progression
significative n'est constatée à partir
du 22 octobre 2022 entre la jungle et
les de la nation c'est c'est en
prévision de de ce timing que le fndc y
compris ses alliés nous avons décidé de
sortir la tenue lourde en fin d'engager
des protestations de rue pour faire
comprendre à la gêne de raison garder
qui n'ont aucune légitimité ils n'ont
aucune légalité d'engager le pays vers
cette dérive mais est-ce que c'est pour
ça aussi que la jungle part va publier
cette liste vu que les gens désignaient
dessus pourraient être subir des
sanctions écoutez et les l'équipe de la
gente est composé à la fois l'homme
d'affaires mais aussi des personnes qui
sont impliquées dans le narcotrafiquant
donc la jungle estime que vouloir
publier cette liste elle se mettrait à
mal avec la communauté internationale
donc la tout intérêt au fait de
travailler dans ce camouflé mais chose
qui ne marchera pas dans la mesure qu'au
niveau du fndc et des autres acteurs
nous exigeons qui est la publication de
la liste des membres du du Seigneur des
mais aussi qui puisse déclarer leur
patrimoine parce que compréhensible que
la jungle puisse engager tout une
bataille de lutte contre la moralisation
de la vie publique tandis que eux-mêmes
ils veulent pas déclarer leur patrimoine
je vous informe que le président du CNRD
est un grand populaire immobilier à
Conakry il dispose un immeuble de R + 10
et je vous informe qui n'est pas moins
de 300 €, donc il est incompréhensible
que ceux qui veulent lutter contre la
corruption et même constat il constitue
aujourd'hui un obstacle pour le pays
mais alors du coup vous qui avez été
interdit par dissous votre mouvement a
été dissout par la par la jante qui vous
accuse de violence
je cite un vous êtes illustré par des
voies de violence dégradation etc la
première votre première réaction à
l'époque en sa date du 8 août vous aviez
vous avez pas reconnu aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que vous demandez finalement à
la gente écoutez cette prétendue
dissolution et illégale et comme vous le
savez la plupart des institutions
internationales et organismes l'ont
dénoncer je parle de la FDH diagnostic
international de la roue commissaire et
cette dissolution les réseaux sont
ailleurs je vous informe qu'en janvier
février et dernier le président du CNRD
a rapproché les leaders du fndc afin de
lui permettre de de
d'influencer les acteurs sociaux
politiques du pays pour les laisser
faire 4 ans de transition on l'a fait
comprendre que 4 ans c'est impossible
qu'on pouvait pas remplacer les jours
nous par les par les armes aussi il nous
a proposé le Président Mamadou Doumbouya
que nous puissions engager toute une
série d'actions en fin de décrédibiliser
et de rendre illégitime les présidents
sudiatouré Cellou Dalein Diallo qui sont
des potentiels candidats aux directions
présidentielles donc le cordateur actuel
du fndc je parle de du Cameroun
actuellement à prison a décliné cette
offre pour lui que c'était un offre
dangereux qui pourrait faire tomber le
pays dans une instabilité donc l'agenda
ils ont un plan machiavélique qui
consiste à éliminer tous les candidats
potentiels qui pourront briguer le la
maltraiture suprême du pays merci
beaucoup c'est coucou
bienvenue je rappelle que vous êtes
responsable stratégie planification du
fndc principal mouvement d'opposition en
Guinée merci beaucoup
la visite du président Bissau guinéen et
en exercice de la CEDEAO en Côte
d'Ivoire ou marron
à la rencontre de son homologue Alassane
Ouattara et au menu des discussions
l'affaire des 46 soldats ivoiriens
détenus par les autorités maliennes la
Guinée mais surtout la situation au
Burkina Faso depuis le nouveau coup
d'État on écoute on écoute au micro de
sadiamundo
moi je pense ça c'est toujours c'est
réglable le coup d'État mais
le rapport que j'ai eu des médiateurs
qui est président Issoufou m'a dit que
le capitaine
Ibrahim Traoré a pris les engagements de
suivre le foot de la CEDEAO donc nous
sommes dans cette voie
le Burkina Faso contre 2 millions de
déplacés la moitié sont des enfants pour
fuir la recrudescence des attaques
terroristes nombre d'entre eux ont
décidé de vivre dans les quartiers
périphériques de Ouagadougou la capitale
burkinabè immersion dans leur monde avec
ce reportage d'ange nomméo Sophie
Lamothe et Damien Coffe
ce quartier reculait de pasani est connu
à Ouagadougou pour ses routes de terre
rouge et ses maisons en pierre
inachevées mais aussi pour abriter des
milliers de Burkinabè déplacés à
l'intérieur du pays ça va Toko est l'un
d'entre eux il a dû fuir dibou en 2019
après une attaque meurtrière dans son
village ce jour-là ils sont venus au
marché et ont tiré en l'air sans arrêt
en 16h et 22h mais ils l'ont tué
personne cette fois là ils sont revenus
quelques jours plus tard et ont fait
irruption dans l'église protestante ils
ont tué le prêtre et 6 de ses fidèles
quand on entend parler de ces dernières
attaques on a toujours un peu peur le
sentiment de traumatisme revient
ça va Dogo à 17 enfants et seulement 6
d'entre eux sont scolarisés comme la
plupart des familles déplacées il n'a
pas les moyens de payer les frais de
scolarité c'est une ONG qui soutient
l'éducation de ses enfants moi je
souhaite quand même que vous puissiez
continuer de l'accompagner sinon
mise en question la moitié des personnes
déplacées à l'intérieur du pays sont des
enfants et la grande majorité d'entre
eux n'ont pas accès à l'éducation cela
pourrait avoir des conséquences à plus
long terme car toute une génération
pourrait bien être exclue de la société
s'il y a pas de structure pour les
accompagner pour les scolariser ça sera
des enfants discuter du degrés qu'on
aura dans 10-15 ans tu vas créer
d'autres soucis pour la population le
Burkinabè espère vivement que leur
nouveau dirigeants ramène la paix et la
sécurité dans le pays mais en attendant
le nombre de personnes déplacées ne
cesse d'augmenter et leurs besoins sont
de plus en plus
urgent
le président Kenya William Routot en
visite en Éthiopie c'est la première
tournée est africaine pour le président
récemment élu il profitera il a profité
de sa présence dans la capitale
éthiopienne a dit-abeba pour discuter de
la coopération bilatérale d'approfondir
les liens économiques et stratégiques
entre les deux pays sur les questions
régionales
quand la justice française se penche sur
des crimes commis pendant la guerre
civile au Liberia le 10 octobre commence
à Paris le procès des assises de
kunticamara un ancien commandant rebelle
soupçonné de crimes contre l'humanité
commis dans les années 90 et c'est une
première en France les explications de
Jonathan watch
un procès inédit comment ce lundi à
Paris sur le banc des accusés County
Camara un ancien chef rebelle libérien
il a été interpellé en France en 2018
suite à la plainte d'une ONG il n'existe
à ce jour aucune image publique de cet
homme de 47 ans County Camara est mise
en examen pour acte de torture et de
barbarie durant la guerre civile au
Liberia de possibles crimes contre
l'humanité qui autorise la justice
française à faire valoir sa compétence
universelle ce procès est important et
vraiment porteur d'espoir puisque
aujourd'hui au Liberia on n'a toujours
pas jugé une seule personne impliquée
dans la guerre civile libérienne c'est
très important pour les victimes de
savoir qu'à l'étranger ces personnes
risquent tôt ou tard d'être confronté à
leur passé
ce procès va se pencher sur les pages
les plus sombres de l'histoire récente
du Liberia les guerres civile qui ont
déchiré le pays entre 1989 et 2003 on
fait près de 250 000 morts
Kunti Camara était un responsable de
loumo un groupe armé opposé à
l'ex-président libérien Charles Taylor
pillage viol meurtre torture l'effet
donc Camara est accusé aurait été commis
entre 1992 et 1997 dans le comté du Lofa
dans le nord-ouest du Liberia un juge
d'instruction français à enquêter sur
place et recueilli de nombreux
témoignages incriminants Kunti Camara
mais ce dernier continue à nier en bloc
comme l'explique son avocate depuis le
départ monsieur Kunti Camara indique
qu'il n'a rien à voir avec ses faits
qu'il n'est pas impliqué dans l'effet
qu'on lui reproche ce qu'il a indiqué
depuis le départ c'est qu'il était un
soldat de lulimo mais qu'à aucun moment
il l'a commis d'acte de torture ou
d'autres crimes sur les civils
le procès va durer près d'un mois si les
jugé coupable County Camara encourt la
prison à perpétuité
c'est la fin de cette édition du journal
Afrique merci à tous ceux qui nous ont
suivi partout dans le monde et un salut
tout particulier à notre collègue voici
une cornet en présentation souvent en
anglais et il va vaquer vers d'autres
destinations américaines en particulier
et nous lui souhaitons tout le meilleur
évidemment
[Musique]